when you talk about computation how do
you think about it do you think purely
on just um the get the switching
or do you think something a little bit
larger scale circuit taken together
performing the basic arithmetic
operations that are then required to do
the kind of
computation that makes up a computer
because when we talk about the speed of
computation is it boiled down to the
basic switching or is there some bigger
picture that you're thinking about well
all right so
maybe we should disambiguate there are a
variety of different kinds of
computation
i don't pretend to be an expert in
the theory of computation or anything
like that i guess it's important to
differentiate though between
digital logic
which represents information as a series
of bits binary digits which you know uh
you can think of them as zeros and ones
or whatever usually they correspond to
a physical system that has two very well
separated states
and then other kinds of computation like
we'll get into more the way your brain
works which
it is i think indisputably processing
information
but
where the computation begins and ends is
not anywhere near as well defined it
doesn't depend on
these two levels here's a zero here's a
one it's there's a lot of gray area
that's usually referred to as analog
computing
also
in in conventional digital computers or
um
digital computers in in general
you have a concept of what's called
arithmetic depth which is jargon that
basically means how many
sequential operations are performed to
turn
an input into an output and those kinds
of computations in in digital systems
are highly serial
meaning that data streams they don't
branch off too far to the side you do
you have to pull some information over
there and access memory from here and
stuff like that but
by and large the the computation
proceeds in a serial manner it's not
that way in the brain in the brain
you're always drawing information from
different places it's much more
network-based computing neurons don't
wait for their turn they fire when
they're ready to fire and so it's it's
asynchronous so one of the other things
about a digital system is you're
performing these operations on a clock
and that's a that's a crucial aspect of
it get rid of a clock in a digital
system nothing makes sense anymore the
brain has no clock it builds its own
time scales based on its internal
activity
so so you can think of the brain as kind
of
like this like network computation where
it's actually really trivial simple
computers
uh
just a huge number of them and they're
networked
i would say it is complex sophisticated
little processors and there's a huge
number of things neurons are not no
i don't mean to offend sure no they're
very complicated and beautiful and yeah
but
we often oversimplify them yes they're
actually like there's computation
happening within a neuron right so i
would say
to think of a a transistor as the
building block of a digital computer is
accurate you use a few transistors to
make your logic gates you build up more
you build up processors from logic gates
and things like that so you can think of
a transistor as a fundamental building
block or you can think of as we get into
more highly parallelized architectures
you can think of a processor as a
fundamental building block to make the
analogy to the
neuro side of things
a neuron is not a transistor a neuron is
a is a processor it has synapses even
synapses are not transistors but they
are more um
they're lower on the information
processing hierarchy in a sense they do
a bulk of the computation but neurons
are entire
processors in and of themselves that can
take in many different kinds of inputs
on many different spatial and temporal
scales and produce many different kinds
of outputs so that they can perform
different computations in different
contexts so this is where it enters this
distinction between computation and
communication so you can think of
neurons performing computation
and the inter
networking the interconnectivity of
neurons is communication routine neurons
and you see this with very large server
systems i've been i mentioned offline
been talking to jim keller whose dreams
to build giant computers that
uh you know
the bottom like there's often the
communication between the different
pieces of computing
you